I'm fascinated by this but you do where
you have to eat something disgusting in
order I know you are you'll really yeah
you could not do that I mean if I was on
your show and you said to me you have to
eat a cow so I think you said to share
share you can either tell me uh
something positive about Donald Trump
yeah or you can eat this cow's tongue
yeah he chose to eat the cows young I
couldn't eat a cow [ __ ] tongue oh
[ __ ] a the interesting thing about that
one was share right so she she came on
the stage this is when we were in London
we've taken the show to London and she
came on and she handed me and when she's
done the show a few times I re I'm
incredibly fond of her she handed me a
piece of paper when she shook my hand
and I opened it and it was like a little
kind of notepad piece of paper and it
said James yeah I don't want to do this
I wish I hadn't agreed to it and I
there's a chance I might
not do it but I want you to know I love
you and I love the show I'm just having
real fears about this the eating thing
yeah look don't worry about all of these
things are delicacies around the world
none of these things like in in many
places some of the they're just odd to
us we're not odd and a lot of it doesn't
taste bad it's name doesn't it's just
your psyche of something being new I was
like I promise you I promise you all of
these things are all safe fine and you
don't have to worry about anything you
just go have a good time and she was
like okay you sure I was like yes just
enjoy it now the last that's funny I
thought you were gonna say it went up to
share and I should share if you don't
want to do it you don't have to do it
don't worry about it
no you said to her hey we've cooked
these things we've made sure that
there's doesn't a mother
this all doesn't matter don't overthink
it don't worry about it
it's gonna be like you've just got to
enjoy this don't worry about it you know